and oh and welcome to the plane nobleman
yep i'm going for efore i want to switch
a little bit play a little bit more
variety of openings whoa q EF six that
looks a tad risky said good wow he plays
it like it's the most normal thing in
the world maybe that's an ID maybe
that's a liner looks a bit strange but
ok so he wants to win that porn I maybe
I just take I mean it's probably not the
refutation but see 3d for coming
shouldn't be too bad and let me care
plate my night a couple of times but yes
he had to play a screen also quite a bit
ok so if i take on c6 and take on e5 hmm
and it's going to play up six and get
the poem bag that's a bit lame kd5 don't
know about d5 what is this next move
probably d6 I wonder if I have something
I can take their take on e5 it doesn't
doesn't do much I can take here and take
with a pawn maybe huh yeah I'm not so
enthusiastic about this black might get
some compensation him now d takes c6 and
D takes d5 you might have some
compensation after f6 again if i take
with the noid sf6 until it gets this
back now i need to keep it
yeah might have some compensation him
yep this kind of thing
20x maybe yeah it isn't so why it isn't
so great iam it's a a bit weird but some
are not so great okay so what now yeah
maybe just back he gets f3 and it's not
so bad for black Bishop I'll be six is
pretty strong so is there a way to get
rid of this rook probably not
oops shouldn't change the window so he
can go to give aid keep press them Jan
not really threatening look Bishop takes
e7 a.m. oh that's nice and now I'm fine
after work trade I'm totally fine now I
can actually move my points that wasn't
clear if I get this and I had could have
played Bishop edge for him stupid I
should have done that I was in precise
visual h4 was game over already ah not
so good I don't like to take them and
probably have to though
capital H 1 of course was a lot better
that would have ended the game
immediately time warning
it's probably a draw but I can try
because of my belly bishop he's got Jack
couple of things on dark squares and now
i'm getting at b6 it wasn't forced and
the a bishop hy at i could have just one
day exchange check taking a five black
resins you came so there's a shaky game
a shaky game yeah a very weird opening
here i never saw that one community of
six I cannot really believe it is great
but ok so he went here like it's the
most normal thing ever yeah I have ways
i have also have c3 maybe sacrifice a
pawn but ok i came out i don't think
that this can be so bad yeah here you
have a have some other options i was
also thinking about g5 but I wasn't
quite sure how good this is the computer
likes it was thinking this and I'm not
sure I mean this is not bad for white
but black definitely has a good Bishop
now and it's got potential at five I
don't really see why white should be
substantially better as the engine is
flaming gym ok I decided to grab that
but black is ok here really I have six
it's definitely an ok position yeah this
I went here and I don't know why he went
woop to f7 I mean Bishop c7 I can take
on f Bishop g7 he can take on f2 so I
don't know why this is necessary so you
do this and maybe you're running out of
moves a little bit yeah that's it's
possible yeah it's difficult like to
make a move him g6 already wasn't quite
happy so the engine wants to take here
maybe and like this this jack and yeah
white has this and b7 this week yeah
maybe he is still in trouble a little
bit I mean this is just better for white
and look at you once more precise I had
this I don't understand the engine I'm
sorry who do you want ok now the
evaluation is going up ok unless this is
ok engine no gives white roughly have a
pawn which is exactly what i was
thinking what should be better here
because he is basically playing with the
next report him no upon yeah ugh d three
was better and now this is the funny I I
mean I was so happy that I had F for
that I just played it immediately
instead this is of course forcing
resignation yeah I was just happy that
the f point came when I did this
straightaway get here the worst is
definitely over for black
yeah and here i think you should draw
with good play which check this is
already spoiling and now I'm billing I
think he probably has to play some
waiting move for a g6 black we should
draw here it's fortress-like I mean
white has the better structure bishop
and pawns but there's no way in in down
check and just do this yeah close game
thanks for watching